[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice ken coleman ramsey personality
number one best-selling author and host
of the ken coleman show is my co-host
today as we take your questions about
your life your money and with ken here
your career all about jobs and all about
careers and all about what you're going
to do on the income side of this money
equation as well as we'll talk to you
about your life and your money open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five john is in new york
city to start off this hour hey john how
are you
hi dave i'm doing well how are you
better than i deserve what's up
awesome uh i had a quick question as far
as
uh i currently live in a co-op
and
within the next three or five years i
plan on moving out into a house so i'm
looking at holding on to the co-op as a
rental property
however
i just don't know if the maintenance
that i'm also paying for the co-op kind
of excludes this as being a useful
rental property
i know there's different values that you
could
work the numbers on but just this for
the simple fact of a maintenance alone
which is actually more
than the mortgage that i pay i have a
30-year mortgage i'm sorry saying
um so i want to know your opinion on
that is it best that i just
sell the co-op when i'm ready to buy a
house or should i actually dig deeper
into the numbers find out
well what we want you to move towards
because it's the shortest distance to
wealth is to being a hundred percent
debt free house and everything
and it sounds like that keeping this
co-op means that you're going to have
debt on the co-op and probably on the
new house as well right
correct yeah so i'm going to move you
away from that i would not buy rental
property
or invest in rental property directly or
indirectly
until i can do it with cash after my
home is paid for
and that's what we teach now that's very
slow
it takes a lot of time
but then you don't get burnt on the
properties it also sounds like that this
particular property even if it were paid
for and your home to buy would be paid
for
still might be a questionable rental
because this maintenance factor might
offset any fund that you'd be having
cash flow wise
right yeah so that's that's pretty much
yeah that's what i imagined the ideal
situation would be within three or five
years me and my current girlfriend would
be married
and
we would fund the house i mean it would
be
in new york it's tough to pay cash for
what we would be looking for so
i just figured i'm living in the co-op
i'm by that time i didn't know if i
should refinance the 15 year even as a
rental but it's not like overall
i would sell it and i would take the
equity to move towards the house and
then have a game plan for getting the
house paid off as soon as possible and
then start talking about saving up and
investing in rental real estate but um
most of the time you don't move out of
your property
into your home and turn the old property
into a
uh
into a rental because most of the time
that means you're gonna involve extra
debt to pull that off yeah and it sounds
from sounds like from a cash flow
standpoint he could be breaking even or
losing money given all the maintenance
stuff that he began to identify there in
addition to that in addition to
everything you gave him yeah and i and i
i mean new york real estate values
obviously are
it's a unique market that we're talking
about in manhattan in particular and so
you know
probably could make up a ton of what he
didn't make on cash flow with increase
in value yes assuming that they don't
continue destroying that town
politically
with covet and cops and everything else
it's a mess i mean it's the worst it's
been in decades
and i'm a huge fan of new york city but
it's a mess right now absolutely and uh
so you know it's
politics matter when it comes to
economics around real estate sure does
economics around your businesses and
that kind of stuff so
that that's what's in play there so
a lot of reasons to not keep this co-op
hey thanks for the call open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five kathleen is with us in milwaukee hi
kathleen how are you
oh i'm doing well thank you um i you
know i've been listening long enough
to know that roth is the rate is the way
to go
my husband has had a
just a traditional 403 b for several
years and now
uh work does offer the roth and i i
think my understanding is is that if he
just stopped
paying into the raw or paying into the
traditional he could open a roth
and
works match would go into the
traditional and then his
um
the stuff that he puts in would go into
the rocks i just wanted to see we don't
have the extra funds right now to pay
the taxes but i just wanted to see if if
we should just do that just stop the
traditional start the ross or if we
should if it's better to like
if interest is better just keeping it
compounding with no it does it does not
affect it does not affect your end
result it does not affect compounding at
all
two two piles compact that are equal
in size to both the piles added together
compounded exactly the same rate
a hundred thousand dollars in two
accounts
compounds
at as 200 000 at exactly the same rate
as 200 000 in one account
okay does not change the math okay so
you just uh don't change that at all but
you're right you don't want to activate
and pay taxes on all of the money that's
sitting there so we'll leave what he's
done to this point in traditional and
you're required to receive the match in
traditional going forward but from this
point forward
his contribution should be in a wrath
and yeah you're doing that exactly
exactly right
so ken it's kind of our rock paper
scissors thing yeah match beats roth
beach traditional and that's what she's
already figured out yeah
yeah it's it and it and it always works
that way you know it's like when people
figure out and the real benefits of what
when we get into the roth it's because
of the tax implications tax free free
when you look up and you got a million
dollars in your account huge difference
and it's all tax free versus it's all
taxable that's
250 350 000 per million issue
that's a lot of money so that word roth
is worth hundreds of thousands of
dollars a letter
so yeah you don't r o t that's 400 grand
right there you know i mean at least
yeah it's it's when you do it over over
a period of your working lifetime it's a
lot of money not to mention i just hate
taxes dave so it has the added benefit
not just the zeros but i just feel
better i don't have to pay taxes i'm
just less pissed off
essentially
that's the emotional and financial
benefit that's it there's a spiritual
benefit yeah
i don't stay angry all the time yeah
that's good i love it that's fun all
right open phones here ken coleman my
co-host today host of the ken coleman
show now heard on over 75 radio stations
siriusxm
as a podcast
and on youtube everywhere great radio
stations or great radio shows are heard
you can pick him up and he's always
talking about your life and your career
and finding your dream gig
new book is out called paycheck to
purpose it's on pre-sale right now we
will ship them to you in the fall when
we actually put them on the street and
you can get a bargain on it right now
with a bunch of add-ons from paycheck to
purpose the clear path to doing work you
love at ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 dollars a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over 70 a month by
switching to pure top just go to
feartalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
here on the ramsey show jennifer is with
me with us in edmond oklahoma hi
jennifer welcome to the ramsay show how
can we help hey big stan um so i am
feeling lost with my job i just started
a new job about three months ago the
last couple have not worked out
and i'm trying to decide if i should go
back to school for counseling or an mba
or just look for another job
okay
so we've got two options there that are
very different counseling or an nba and
so i hear you laughing here which is
okay
but i mean where'd those choices come
from are those just out of nowhere or
something you've been thinking about for
a while
thinking about for a long time which one
is the longest in your head and heart
that's the thing i can't decide i feel
like counseling is more what i'm really
good at okay and if i could talk to
people all day that's what i do okay now
there's okay now there are the clues so
let's start with talent okay so we talk
about talent passion and mission these
are the three indicators that every
human being has when we talk about stage
one of my seven stages to do what you're
born to do let's get clear so let's look
at the indicators talent
so what talents do you think a counselor
needs to have that are non-negotiable
what would you say give me two or three
like
empathy
listening yep
being really good with people great okay
so i would call that communication
connection and compassion right
all right so so you've got those in
spades if i interviewed everybody that
knows you would they say jennifer's
really gifted in those areas yes or no
yes all right so doesn't it also stand
to reason jennifer that the things that
we're good at those talents we actually
enjoy using those talents and you you
said so beautifully
if i could listen to people all day long
that would be great but it's not just
the listening part
what fires you up when you're listening
to people what happens next after you
listen to them
kind of coaching them along giving them
advice just connecting with people
fantastic this is easy dave we don't
really need to talk much more with
jennifer because it's very obvious the
type of work that you would love to do i
want to know the why though is there
something from your story whether you
experienced it or you
observed
this that it's been a long time of
thinking about counseling others and
being a guide to them what's in your
story that gives you the why behind this
well i just know that i really want to
help others and i know um i had a family
member
die from mental struggles a few years
ago
and you know just
i've struggled with mental health and i
know so many people yeah and i just know
i can help them i know you can and
that's what i want you to hold on to
right now because in the days ahead as
you begin to strike a path forward
you're going to have times of fear
and doubt and you've got to you've got
to kind of strike those just
just cross them out right align right
through them whatever the voice is and
go back to the why that you just shared
with us so not the nba the answer is no
no to the nba but yes to what do i have
to do to get qualified to be a counselor
to serve those people
okay
so you got why uh why
so many jobs in the last while
why are you
i am currently doing um engineering
and i'm just the remoteness has been
really hard not talking to anybody has
been really tough oh so they got your
own work from home yeah oh yeah not to
mention it's not work that you love you
don't love the work you just kind of
fell into it and you're just trying to
search for something instead of you have
an engineering degree
yep yeah okay how old are you
38 okay
but why did you bounce around
what were the others
it's been at the same company um the
last one it just it didn't fit so if i
mean another one
and i agreed to it and it just it has i
thought it'd be more people interaction
has not been and it just has not been a
good fit
yeah
so now we got to switch gears and you
got to go get educated to be a counselor
so you got to do your homework on that
what's that going to cost how long is
that going to take i have them that's
not a bit that's not an issue for for us
it's just not knowing what to do now
well what to do now is is you got to
plan this thing so you know are you
going to go full time you got to go part
time how's that going to affect
the next decision which is am i working
my way through am i going full time
those are the things you got to pick a
school do not get sucked into the brand
name decision nobody cares where you get
your counseling degree
nobody okay do you understand what i'm
saying so don't get sucked into well
number time someone sits down with a
marriage counselor and say our mental
health counselor and says uh before we
start i'd like to know where you
graduated from is zero yeah
that's right it's zero
so the only thing that matters is the
quality of the information the quality
of the knowledge that okay yeah so i
mean when i sit down on my dock i don't
know where my doctor went to get med
school i don't even ask him it's like
was it bragging rights that he went to
my doctor went to who gives a crap are
you well
so are you okay that's true did he fix
your broken whatever yeah that's what
matters here
can you get the help and don't fall into
that and and you know take a take the
track uh as a 38 year old that is not
the traditional college track as well
something that uh shortcuts you straight
into that yeah you got an engineering
degree maybe there's some stuff you can
overlay on this and and get straight
into that master's program pretty quick
uh because you'll have to get a masters
in every state in order to be licensed
as a counselor ashley's in jacksonville
florida hey ashley what's up
hi guys um thank you so much for taking
my call um i just have a quick question
trying to figure out if we bought too
much house in 2020
um my husband and i did baby got to baby
step six in 2018 and 2019 paying off our
debt um and paying off about 30 percent
of our house
and then decided we wanted to find a
better home home for family somewhere
that we could be as intentional as we
were but actually enjoy where we were
living
but we got back into debt doing it which
is terrible please don't yell at me
um we got about thirty five thousand
dollars into debt um and we just paid
that off last month so we are happily in
baby step three um
but now that we're moving towards baby
step four and the percentages of like
how much my house payment is obviously
gonna go it's gonna be more of my income
since i'm going to be putting 15 into
investment and i'm just trying to figure
out
if we bought too much house
well the investment does not affect your
housing formula
15 going into investments doesn't affect
that what's your gross pay or your your
net pay not counting what goes into 401k
not counting what goes into health
insurance but just net of taxes
net of taxes what's your household
take-home pay
um and that's
sorry that's after taxes i'm not great
with the lingo after taxes
what's your
taxes i i don't know the annual income
but it's about 8 000 a month
okay and how much is your house payment
um 21.62
that's like a fourth i mean what's the
problem it's almost the fourth i wasn't
sure if you know because we're about to
get to baby step four and i was worried
once the 15
um started coming out obviously that
dramatically changes how much we could
be putting towards the house and our
biggest goal is kind of getting that
thing paid off so well you're gonna put
15 at baby step four of your income
towards retirement but that does not
affect the calculation of your house
payment being 25 of your take-home pay
because your take-home pay is not what
comes out take-home pay means after
taxes
and so
so you're making a hundred thousand so
you're probably making a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars a year gross
does that sound about right yeah okay
yeah that sounds right yeah and so
you're fine on this there's nothing
wrong here you're going to put 15 away
and then you're going to have to begin
to chip away at the mortgage beyond that
as you work through baby steps five and
six kids college and anything extra you
can find you put on the house but your
house payment is not going to keep you
from putting 15 down or 15 into
retirement it's it's just not you're not
house poor not even close
so i i think what you did was you uh
took a step up and it's a bigger payment
than you're emotionally used to and it
just smacked you around a little bit
which is not a bad thing
uh that you that you recognized it
because the the people that are scarier
are the ones that don't realize
that there was a an emotional shift here
and uh ouch you can get that sneak up on
you and get you
so good stuff hey thank you for the call
open phones here ken coleman ramsey
personality is my co-host today again
author of the brand new book on pre-sale
from paycheck to purpose the clear path
to doing work you love
you can pick up a copy at
ramseysolutions.com
and uh it'll be shipped to you with all
kinds of goodies as soon as it actually
comes out but it's on pre-sale right now
which means there's a bargain around it
only 20 bucks and you get about 150
worth of goodies with it be sure and
check it out ramsey solutions.com
[Music]
[Music]
so
in the lobby of ramsay solutions on the
debt free stage joy and her mom ruth are
with us hey guys how are you
very good thank you and you better than
i deserve it's an honor to have you
where do you guys live chihuahua mexico
it's about three hours from el paso
texas oh yeah
wow so an international debt free screen
right here very cool so uh how much did
you pay off about 119 000
119 000. how long did this take about
four years four years okay and uh what
was the range of your income during this
time was it personal debt or what is a
business were self-employed it was about
uh 250
000 average
okay all right so what kind of business
was this it's a tree nursery my mom and
brother and i we have a tree nursery we
grow and sell trees oh okay fine what
kind of trees
anything fruit trees evergreen trees
bushes whatever you want good all right
so tell me the story what happened here
119 000 of business debt paid off in
four years yes
when i was a teenager it started about
before that when i was a teenager my dad
at the time was listening to different
people and he told us kids i have three
brothers to listen to dave ramsey
and you were talking about spending
while living on nothing and spending
less money and i thought well we already
live on nothing we
had no vacations and no
nothing of that sort not really and um
and then
so we forgot about you and then end of
2016
um i started doing the business
papers the expenses and all of that and
i realized how very messy and
unorganized it was just terrible and
so i started googling anything i could
find on business advice and this one day
your name popped into my head i believe
was the holy spirit that gave it to me
and
so i started listening to you searching
for you and i loved it i got very
excited i wanted to get organized and
then about two weeks after that um
my dad got diagnosed with bone cancer oh
my and he did not have insurance so all
the money went to that directly right
away we couldn't pay off anything then
in 2017
we started paying off a little bit
but the majority we paid off uh 2019 to
2021.
and uh
i take it since he's not here he didn't
didn't survive the bone cancer no he he
died
two years ago i'm sorry
i'm sorry you guys have been through a
lot yes
so uh so the the kiddos step in and help
run the business then that's what it
amounts to yes they did i was very
thankful for that amen yes amen and
obviously very capable yes yes and then
some
capable plus yeah very good well good
job so
uh
a horrible way to end up in charge but
you're in charge at this point and uh
joy and you start hammering the data i
guess is what you're saying yeah yeah he
was very mad at that
very mad and so but your advice it was
very practical for us uh i was expecting
for looking for business i'd buy
something high where i would not be able
to reach and it was so common sense so
thank you for that i i really learned a
lot we all did my brothers as well they
got very excited about it now i don't
get a lot of calls from mexico so did i
did you call in
yes i did how long ago
i'd say about one one to two years i
okay this is coming back to me oh
you were working you're starting to work
the plan
chihuahua and tree nursery yeah that's
starting to ring a bell a little bit
yeah i think i mean if it was somewhere
else i might it might not have
remembered it because it all kind of
runs together but that does ring a bell
so you called in a couple of years ago
yes was that nice to you you were very
nice
do you remember what your question was
regarding yes i wanted to ask about the
business exactly because it did not
bring much profit or hardly any and then
so i was wondering how in the world are
we going to pay the stat off if we do
not have any profit and was it either to
sell the business or to
yeah i was clueless what to do with it
and
you mentioned if the profit was going to
be a bit more if we could get the profit
a little bit higher to pay off the doubt
we should do that otherwise solid and so
we tried that and it worked we we did
pay off so you got to keep going what
did you do to to juice that profit
actually just getting organized we had
so much money going out everywhere that
we didn't even know about and me and my
brother uh one of the the one that's
with me now working on it uh and she as
well we just all very intensely tracked
all the expenses and income income and
that gave us a little wiggle room we had
been very disorganized
yes and with my husband being sick
um the nursery was left behind so when
he died we started organizing it again
it was very overwhelming
too
how long did it take to to kind of get
the chaos out six months or a year a
year or maybe even two yeah yeah
and but it's a lot he's more peaceful to
run it yes now without the chaos with
systems and organization right yes
yes and we had a lot of trouble in the
meantime trying to pay off debt like the
trucks were old they were breaking down
and
and flat tires and and the irrigation
system was wasn't working we had to fix
that again and again and
yeah a lot of hard work mm-hmm
but you made it yes and here you are
with no doubt
how's it feel
very amazing and you come all the way to
tennessee yes to do your debt-free
script
well we are honored we're honored you
guys you ladies are
your family your heroes for fighting
your way through this that's pretty
incredible great entrepreneurial story
it really is it's fascinating to see how
they turned it around just organization
getting control of the outflow the
expenses that's the story pretty amazing
stuff and is this this has got big-time
potential i'm guessing now that you've
got this thing running well i really
hope so that's what i'm aiming for good
for you well she has a profit now that's
a profit is a start yeah
enables you to fix flat tires on trucks
easier yeah
[Laughter]
oh my goodness we also cash flowed my
youngest brother's wedding also in the
middle of it all right so how many
brothers and sisters how many siblings
three brothers three brothers and you
all right
all right are you the oldest
i'm in the middle you're in the middle
okay well actually there's one boy um
he's the oldest he manages all the the
nursery she manages the the expenses and
all the money
and her she has a twin brother which we
have here
and then the youngest brother he works
for his uncle right now okay all right
cool that's wonderful it's a great
family business so what do you tell
people the key joy you did it what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of that is
perseverance and determination that's it
i could not have done it without i yeah
a lot of stubbornness in a good way
because it was hard it was very hard but
plus trusting god
amen learning on a on a higher level to
trust god
and we we also wanted to give like we
during that time all of it when my dad
was sick there were so many people they
were generous and they came and visited
and just so willing to give and
um that looked so beautiful to me
so we hope to be that way too we want to
give and be kind to other people i wish
my spanish was as good as your english
where'd you learn your english both of
you
high school from little on just just
part of the part of the curriculum yeah
okay wow very cool
wonderful very fun
so proud of you ladies and gentlemen
very well done very well done well we've
got a copy of the legacy journey for you
that's the uh for sure what you've been
involved in here is legacy type work and
uh that's the next chapter in the story
for it to continue very cool um
best debt-free scream in a while yeah
pretty neat love this very neat very
neat and also a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away to someone
thank you and uh if you prefer it in
spanish both of them are available in
spanish just to hand out to friends or
whatever that's uh happy to help you
either way whatever whatever is good for
you so excellent excellent excellent all
right it's joy and her mom ruth from
chihuahua mexico they paid off the
nursery they paid off the
the uh the tree business and made it man
absolutely amazing 119 000 paid off in
four years 250
000 a year top line on the business
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two
one debt-free
and worth a trip to nashville
that's fun
i love it so beautiful
so well done
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
open phones of triple eight eight two
five five two two five amy's in dallas
hi amy how are you
i'm good mr ramsay how are you better
than i deserve what's up in your world
well okay so
i've been very blessed with financial
wellness mainly because ever since i was
about five
i was always asking my dad questions and
so he taught me
a lot of your principles really
so when i first graduated college
i
figured out what i needed to live on
and saved all the rest pretty much
so what that trickled down to is i'm now
married i have two kids
and
i had been investing in my company stock
for a long time thinking
this is going to be my kids college fund
until i actually have them because i
can't put a five to nine
on a blank person
but now that i have a good chunk of
money in there because i didn't take it
out because it was just skyrocketing so
i figured i'd ride the wave
but now i have a my daughter's five and
my son is two
i'm thinking
you know maybe i should withdraw some of
this and pull the trigger
and pay off the house which is our only
debt and
front load
both of their five two nines so that i
don't have to think about it ever again
do you have enough stock to do both of
those things
it's about 450 000 so yes and how much
is do you own your home
70 000
yeah you need to do this tonight
okay i figured you'd probably say that
but i was just a little worried about
the tax implications of a big
lump sum of money getting
being given to me well what do you think
the uh what do you think your gain on it
is what do you have invested in this 400
000 yeah honestly i think the gains are
like 300 and keep in mind i don't have
to sell all of it because obviously if i
front load a 529 i could put like 90k
and 1 and 30k in the other and based on
calculations i think that'll be okay
when they turn 18.
um and then 70k on the house and so i
should still have like 200k left over in
there but on the gains of that 200k
especially if i strategically sell like
not the ones that were purchased within
the last year
uh
you know i think my gains on it it's
probably a hundred thousand dollars yeah
you yeah you select it's not that big a
deal it's a 15 capital gains rate you've
owned it more than a year and so it's 15
grand per hundred grand
it's not that big a deal okay so yeah
you need to you need to do this
yesterday
and then you know and when you're
selling it you select the shares that
you last purchased
last in first out is the accounting
principle on this meaning that the most
expensive shares
the ones you have the most invested in
will create the least gain
and that should be the last ones you
purchased
so that you know
as you know as you're and then as you're
dealing with it you want to go with last
in first out
okay then what do i do after that
because now it's like
well then you have 200 000 sitting in
stock still do you want that
i don't i don't invest in single stocks
and i don't advise people to more than
10 of their net worth
so is your net worth over 200 000
i mean i'm sorry over 2 million over 2
million
1.3 i think so so i think you're a
little heavy in a single stock even
after we execute the debt free on the
house and the kids uh at five two nines
are set up i'd probably go a different
i'd probably liquidate some of that and
move towards mutual funds i i'm i'm not
as big a player as you are i wanna i
don't want that much risk
claire is in denver colorado hey claire
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
okay so i have a little bit of like a
double life going on um i am an
accountant and i'm also a professional
mma fighter
and i'm having some you're an accountant
wait a minute wait i don't want to drive
past that too quick
you're an accountant by day and an mma
fighter by night
yeah it's like a superhero
yeah like a superhero right clark kent
yeah
but uh yeah yeah so so what happened
this week is um
so i had a little bit of a
head trauma nothing super serious but it
was unexpected and i was having some
side effects so i had to go see a
specialist um so i went to see a
neurologist and basically um all of a
sudden i had a 2500 bill
uh and that's for my whole treatment
like it was actually a very reasonable
price and whatnot um but i only had a
thousand dollars in my emergency fund
so i used that and then i had to
unfreeze the credit card that i was
paying off and put the balance on that
card which you know is not something i
was wanting to do
um and i'm still paying off debt i've
got about 22 000
left in my debt uh
so yeah so at this point um
i'm just trying to figure out if maybe i
need to pad my emergency fund a little
more for the time being
before i can get to that third baby step
or how i should handle this
wow
okay so
uh
head trauma is not an unexpected event
when you are an mma fighter
right that's a predictable event
right i mean logically yeah
i've never participated but i've watched
what you do and
i'm scared of you right now
[Laughter]
uh so uh uh
have you made money
fighting so i'm at the point right now
i'm actually in a really good spot i
fight for a good organization but the
way mma works is you're making very
little money until you're making a lot
of money so right now
from fighting i make about 15 grand a
year okay let's bank let's bank that as
a business let's bank that to the side
as a business
and hope you break even with medical
bills
right
so take a take run your life on your
accounting income
and set the mma
aside as a as a small business idea and
say this small business is going to
break even if we're lucky
okay okay
and then you can just bank that money
and they and instead of changing the
baby steps let's just qualify this as a
small business because it legitimately
is it's a side hustle
and uh you know and so how long have you
been doing this i'm interested
uh i've been doing this for i think
about six years all together i had a
long amateur career and i'm a
professional so it's been a journey
so how long have you been pro
i've been pro
uh for about i think it's only been
about two years right now so far how old
are you i'm 25. okay
so you you figure you got what five
years on the ring more
you know i'm hoping ten more years so
that's also why i'm taking this brain
stuff real seriously and you know after
that i want to do accounting for the
rest of my life so
yeah so you really can't afford to get
your eggs scrambled doing that then
right yeah exactly exactly i just wonder
i've got to ask this is quick
do you allow the frustration of the
accounting to get you mad enough to
punch somebody or do you love the
accounting
you know i really love the accounting i
honestly i feel like i'm living the
dream i love god for you that's great
that is so fun yeah and so you're so
you're you're probably a very technical
fighter then
yes yes exactly yeah very cool well fun
claire well that's neat first first mma
fighter question we've had so yeah
you're the first shooter
i'll have more moving forward especially
when the money starts rolling in so i'll
probably remember the call because it's
it's it's not one i get all the time so
you call back anytime we can help that's
interesting
very fun
aren't you a little scared right now ken
oh god there's no question in fact in
fact i just wonder how long i could last
in the ring with her i think three times
it's too late you already you couldn't
it's over not till you finish the
sentence yeah you'll be done as long as
it would take for her to catch up to me
it's the real answer
tap out from his head hitting the ground
she wouldn't even have to strike me i
don't think
is the real answer
they don't allow guns in there so i'm
not going in there
[Laughter]
i'm too scared i'm just really scared
that's fun that is awesome oh man i'm a
tough lady yeah that's that's an
interesting way of looking at something
though i mean
she's
looking at this business through the
eyes of an accountant what a real
question what an interesting thing
that's very cool well that puts this
hour of the ramsey show in the books ken
coleman uh my co-host james childs my
producer kelly daniel my associate
producer and phone screener i'm dave
ramsey your host and we'll be back
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world subscribe or follow today
wherever you listen to podcast
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice ken coleman ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
your money and with ken here
particularly your career his new book is
on pre-sale right now soon to be a best
seller from paycheck to purpose
the clear path to doing work you love
it's on sale for twenty dollars at
ramseysolutions.com along with about 150
worth of goodies and all kinds of good
things happening there so open phones
here at triple eight eight two five
five two two five
ken the exciting thing about the sale of
your new book has been not only the
sales are amazingly high on the book we
knew it would be popular it's a an area
of life that people need help in from
paycheck to purpose
but the assessment that our team and you
put together
um
the details and the uh algorithms and
the stuff behind the scenes you didn't
do the team did but it was done with
your input to get the uh
to get people to recognize their talents
passions and missions it's a thirty
dollar assessment it's called the get
clear assessment matter of fact for
thirty dollars you can get the
assessment and the book and all the
goodies if you wanna do it that way as a
bundle at ramsey solutions or you can
just get the assessment for 30 bucks if
you want which would not be the right
way to do it really but you could you
ought to get the book and stuff free in
a sense if you're absolutely the other
way but anyway so uh this is a tool for
people that are
trying to figure out what their career
should be what direction they should be
they need to get clear right that's
right or it could be confirming a path
that you're already on and you're
experiencing some doubt so what we do is
this is the tool in the first stage of
the seven stages the clear path that
we're talking about here in the book
from paycheck to purpose the baby steps
is a clear path and then we have a clear
path and stage one is get clear so what
you're doing is you're gonna look at uh
your talent this is what you do best
thing of your talent is tools so you've
got your hard skills and then people
skills then you got passion and and that
is the work that you actually love to do
you love the work you show up because
the work itself is something you get
great joy out of and then of course all
work creates results and that's what we
call mission so what's the missional
result that you want to put into the
world through your work and so the
assessment dave is going to give you a
detailed report on your top talents your
top passions and that that really that
top mission result that you want to put
out then we take those results and we
put them in a purpose statement and it
becomes a guide for you it becomes a
north star that no matter what decisions
you're confronted with with
opportunities to move up in your career
you can always come back and say is this
something that is in my purpose
statement my professional purpose we
call that that sweet spot where people
look at you and they marvel and they say
you were born to do this and so that's
what the the assessment does for people
dave is tremendous clarity which as you
know breeds confidence in people to step
out and do that work and here's what
else clarity provides it also provides
courage in those moments where fear and
doubt or failure
pride stick their ugly head up and kind
of say you can't do this you shouldn't
do this and that's what clarity does for
you so it is a wonderful tool
that will keep you clear throughout your
career the get clear assessment at
ramseysolutions.com
ken um what occurs to me here is is that
uh
the first thing you have to do when it
comes to a job
is you have to make some money to feed
your family provision absolutely and
prevent pay the bills keep the lights on
keep the wolf away from the door so go
make some money yes but pretty quickly
after you're making money
you know regardless of how much money it
is you can be making a lot of money if
you're in the wrong thing that you
weren't designed to do
uh it starts to become dissatisfying
even though all the bills are paid it's
exactly right it starts to twist up
inside your stomach
and it's the old maslow's hierarchy of
needs you reach the point that you can
self-actualize which means that we're
going to go do something that is a
higher calling than simply earning money
to eat or pay off debt there is nothing
dishonorable
about earning money no just to pile up
debt and and or to pay off debt and to
pile up some money uh but as through
this particularly on the short term yes
that's not a bad thing at all go make
some money you know for provision
purposes but it doesn't
but sooner or later hopefully sooner
you're going to look up and go i don't
need to spend my whole life just chasing
the almighty dollar that's exactly right
and this is because we as human beings
long to make a contribution so the title
from paycheck to purpose really
addresses those two primary needs around
work we need to provide
and we need to contribute we just do
nobody ever has to teach a human being
to to ask the question what should i do
with my life you know i got three kids
dave you have three kids you got all
kinds of grand babies now i can't even
keep up nobody has to teach a kid to say
no
he's just adult they have to teach a kid
to steal a toy from another kid it's
just who we are and the same is true of
this longing that we have as human
beings to make a difference and the idea
here is is that you can make the income
that you need and desire and the impact
that you desire income and impact
through your work is purpose and that's
what we're about here ramsey solutions
you know you walk through our our
building and hope you come visit us
sometime and you'll see on the giant
screen just you know off through the
glass there work that matters we're all
about doing work that matters and we see
a contribution through everything we do
at ramsey solutions as it relates to
providing people a clear path to hope
and and that's missional and every human
being wants to show up and do work that
matters to them it's it's just life's
too short dave to chase a paycheck
and just try to make it through till
friday at happy hour and what's really
interesting and
you know intellectually it's easy to
grasp this but i think emotionally i you
only grasp it maybe when you get the
other side of it is
if you will find something that you're
talented at that you're missional about
and that you're passionate about
um
you actually if you'll just pay
attention to the process you'll end up
making a lot more money doing that a lot
more than you would doing the thing
that's supposed to be money-based that's
right but you're not good at or you hate
that's exactly right here's why because
you suck at things you hate that's
exactly right and listen you won't press
through
yeah you won't fight it you won't fight
through that like you know if we look at
your story dave somebody comes at this
place i got a thousand people going
after their throat oh yeah because
they're all ready to fight i mean it's a
crusade here well this please don't mess
with this place because this place is
blessing people and helping people and
loving people and and so somebody comes
at the place all
thousand team members are like
that's exactly right but people know
your story
this place was built on your passion and
mission
yes you had the talent you've always
been a good communicator and a teacher
it's one of your top talents
but the reality is is that you care
deeply about guiding people and
instructing people
and the mission was hope and peace and
so now when you see all this it's worth
fighting through your side hustle which
becomes your own company one day or it's
worth fighting through the ladder of
getting promoted and staying with it
long enough you'll suffer because of
passion and mission suffer through
patience suffer through perseverance
check out the get clear
assessment
invited as a bundle with the from
paycheck to purpose book the clear path
to doing work you love all at
ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at ch
ministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five
five
two two five duane is with us in boise
idaho hi dwane how are you
i'm doing better than i deserve how are
you two doing today just the same sir
how can we help
dave um been able to listen to your show
on and off for the last couple of months
and i've been trying to work these baby
steps and
i got rid of all my consumer debt so i
paid all that off and the last debt i
had was a truck that i sold back to my i
got rid of my pickup last week to the
dealer so i have no debt wow so i'm debt
free but what i do have
is i have two rental properties
in a neighboring town to boise here
and one of them i owe 54 on and the
other one i owe 120 on
and they're both at 475 or 489 interest
rate because i've had them for many
years
but they are they have been rented by
the same tenants for a long time
the one that i owe 54 000 on is rented
by an
an 80 something gentlemen and i promised
him that he could live throughout the
rest of his life there at that house
and i
what i want to do is i want to find out
is it's smart for me
to take an equity loan out on that house
and pay off the other property complete
there's enough money there to do that
um
well with the equity line would the
equity line be a cheaper interest rate
oh absolutely
absolutely it would be down to three
3.6 the guy told um my mortgage broker
told me
so
um
what's that property worth of 54 000 on
it
um about 225.
225 to 240 and you'd be in it at 270
right or 170.
yeah but it would pay off the other
property which i want to keep that's
i want to keep the one that the 120 on
it's a lot nicer property that's where
my wife and i plan to live once we
retire
the other property when this gentleman
either moves out or passes away i want
to sell that property so there's the
dilemma
my financial situation the way we're at
it's just my wife and i we don't have
any kids i got about 25 grand in the
bank and we rent currently
so
why but i want to i want i want that
property debt free
okay why do you rent
uh we just moved back into boise for the
last 20 years i've been traveling around
the country for work
and we
we just that's how i wound up with two
rental properties so
um we're looking right now i can use my
va to uh buy a property here locally so
my wife and i would like to buy a house
here locally because the two rental
properties that we have they cash flow
themselves they don't cost us anything
in fact i make money on them what's your
house what's your household income
uh 150 000
my wife is a stay-at-home housewife and
bible instructor she hasn't worked in
almost 20 years and so the income is all
mine that comes from me cool good stuff
guys well done all right well so the
goal you're just like you said you just
got plugged into us so the the long-term
goal where we're aiming towards with
whatever move you choose to do
is that you own your home
paid for
and you own your rental properties paid
for that needs to be the long-term goal
okay okay um
and so no i would not use a va loan i
would use a fannie mae and scratch
together some down payment because it's
cheaper
the va loan is a more expensive loan
interest rate and fees
uh you can yes you can do nothing down
but i'm not going to recommend nothing
down
because the goal is we're going to try
and get your house paid off so let's
work that through then if we uh with
that in mind if you buy a house on a
15-year fixed where the payment's no
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
and you say all right i'm to start
scratching towards that house and then
when the gentleman moves away from the
other property uh you sell that property
and you use that money to pay off your
rental and pay off your home right
correct yes that's going to be the game
plan that's where we're headed
um what does it change to go ahead and
pay off that other rental now with a
home equity loan it only changes the
formula about 1 of 120 000 so about 1200
a year
that's the only thing it moves to move
the mortgage over there doesn't really
do anything except about a thousand
bucks a year
so uh which is what you'll save in
interest by moving it over there if you
don't get into a bad mortgage deal of
some kind and um uh so i i probably
wouldn't screw with it i'd probably just
sit on it it's not that big a savings
if you want to move it over there you
can
because it is going to be cheaper but
it's not it doesn't move the needle here
there's no
uh big thing that happens that's good as
a result of doing this the big thing
that happens that's good is when you
sell one of these properties and clear
your house and clear the other one
yeah
i i
the uh
something wrong in here check it again
there try one more time
nothing try plugging it in
[Laughter]
okay uh ken's mike's uh got unplugged in
here it's got an air gap
[Laughter]
so anyway that's what you're going to
want to do sheldon uh uh
i'm sorry dwayne that's the direction
you're going to want to go and um that
that's the process so uh
yeah
and i think the game plan is is that the
guy that's 80 years old it's going to be
a fairly
you know probably in the next five years
or so you're going to execute the uh
getting rid of that and making that
happen so good question man thank you
for joining us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you wanna check it
nope
all right uh let's go to sheldon in los
angeles hi sheldon welcome to the ramsay
show
hey dave how you doing better than i
deserve how can i help
um so
basically i'm in a dilemma right now um
so i have i have a 2014 volkswagen jetta
it is financed uh it is on a five-year
finance uh apr is nineteen percent
yes i'm paying 330 basically 334 a month
um on it so uh my engine basically is is
done i need a new engine um i spoke to
the mechanic so they are saying the
estimate was gonna be uh it could be in
the range of like five thousand dollars
so on that note i am working part-time
uh and literally i know that's something
that i can i do not have at this moment
in time so my question is
should i sell the vehicle even though it
is finance should i sell a vehicle and
uh again i've been staying up on you
know what you were saying as far as you
know putting cash on a vehicle and also
i was wondering should i do that or you
know what the other solution would be
what are you making what's your income
um right now i am at
i'll say what roughly a month is uh is
at 800 a month why are you not working
full-time
um at this moment in time that's what
i'm actually just working towards
working full-time why are you not
working why are you not working
full-time
i was working full-time i ended up
basically uh
getting something that could be better
potential as far as
benefits and all that for myself as a
full-time job that i did have they
didn't have benefits
yeah but your job sucks
800 bucks that's the poverty level
yes
you're starving to death man
you know yes if the other job you had
was bad and this one's worse you need a
different job and you're not even
working full-time
yeah why i um i'm in a process though i
did interview
could possibly have something full-time
um within a week oh god it's just
something that could be better yeah
actually so it's basically it's in the
company that i'm at um i work for the
city so i work for city working my way
up so it could possibly be a full-time
job that is with ben it needs to be a
full-time job by friday dude
i mean you're starving to death
um so you probably need to sell the car
as is
with a bad engine
and you're probably gonna have to borrow
some money to cover the difference
because you're in the hole but get
getting rid of a 19
car loan and get you a thousand dollar
hoopty to drive around while you get
yourself some good employment
but uh man you can get a job
you're starving
that's really and there's lots of jobs
out there ken and i'll talk about that a
little bit when we come back here
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
auto insurance companies love to play
the game where they see just how high
they can jack up your rates
seems like for no reason doesn't it
it's a fun game for them
it's not hard to beat them at their own
game though all you gotta do is check on
your policy every year and make sure
you're getting the best price for your
coverage that's it
how can you do that well the easiest way
is let someone else shop it for you
go to one of our endorsed local
providers one of our elps they're
independent insurance agents which means
they actually work for you because
they're shopping a bunch of different
companies to get the best price
and then you'll take the deal that's the
best price that they help you find you
don't have to do anything but call them
a lot of people going to our elps end up
saving on their auto and homeowners as
much as seven eight hundred dollars a
year
and it doesn't cost anything to shop it
so just ask
text auto to 33
789 and put a ramsey trusted elp agent
on your team
text auto
uh
233789
and i were talking going into the break
actually i was talking we were fixing
ken's microphone yes yes yes but um i
was talking to ken anyway even though he
couldn't talk back
and uh
the jobs numbers are out so
i was a i'm aware of those numbers
because we had been talking about them
an hour or two ago actually off air
and then the guy calls in and he's
working part-time
and he doesn't have the money to fix an
engine in his car and he's got a 19
interest rate needs to get rid of the
car and all i can talk about is get a
job get a job get a job and that's not
because i'm a heartless jerk it's
because
dude
you can fall off a log you can get a job
right now the jobs and numbers are i
mean you can be dumber than a log and
get a job right now because the jobs
numbers are i'm it's bizarre what's
happening out there
record numbers so the june labor
department report came out monday and
we've got 10 million plus jobs open
available right now in the united states
and you compare that to 8.7 million
people that are still unemployed many
choosing to be unemployed they're still
getting the federal unemployment
benefits that are set to expire on labor
day ironically enough wait wait a minute
wait a minute the unemployment ends on
labor day yeah yeah so maybe it's time
to start planning to labor yeah yeah
sometime before then yeah and the
opportunities are endless dave
million plus jobs here's some good news
in this job report because you hear a
lot of doom and gloom
so the ramsey show is going to give you
the truth this is straight from the
labor department
if you look at the jobs 227
000 professional and business services
jobs
opened up in the month of june now
that's your white collar i think
corporate jobs this is really
encouraging 133 000
jobs in
retail that speaks to consumer
confidence that's a good sign and then
accommodation and food services that's
121 000 jobs added opened
right now
uh it's really unbelievable and and
here's the thing you and i were talking
about during the break you got companies
like walmart mcdonald's
and target that have all announced in
the last 10 days
that they're offering tuition they will
pay for your college tuition
and these these are these are jobs that
dave are starting at 15 an hour it's not
a this young man could go get employed
right now and not just make financial
progress but make some career progress
so 15 an hour
working 40 hours a week only yes just 40
which is really not working that hard
um
is 31 000 a year and free tuition
yeah can really jump start your life
it's better than eight hundred dollars a
month
a year which is what he was making so
that was my point is there's 8.7 million
people unemployed there's 10 million
jobs
it sounds like we don't have any
unemployment it just sounds like we have
people not working that's exactly what
it is there's a difference and what a
great time to go get hired right now my
goodness employers will throw jobs at
you to your point earlier yeah i mean
we're in the process of hiring now we're
in a different league yes because of the
type of elite person we're looking for
at ramsey solutions but we're adding 300
positions this year and
we've got a tons of um bazillions of
applications yeah and uh so
i mean if you can go work at walmart
make 15 bucks an hour work 40 hours and
go to school full time which you can do
by the way yes simultaneously uh go
through and get your degree don't tell
me you have to take out a student loan
and don't tell me you're starving to
death that's just ridiculous that's
exactly right and here's the deal those
dominoes are still beginning to fall
you're going to see a lot of other big
companies that are going to offer
tuition it's going to become a thing
sadly that people expect
but companies are in a position right
now where they've got to attract people
i mean this is literally when we've got
10 million
you have to attract jobs not from other
companies you got to just attract them
off their couch that's the problem
because they're sitting there making
listen let me just talk to you if you're
sitting on your couch living off of
unemployment right now i'll just help
you with this okay it's not shaming
this is just factual life from papa dave
okay
there is no dignity
in your life when you are not
accomplishing something with your life
even if you are making a few dollars
more sitting on your couch then you
could be working
you are not moving your life your career
your wealth building the dignity of your
relationships ahead
by sitting there even if you make more
isn't it well i'm not going back to work
i make less work well i mean now how
much less really but maybe you ought to
work more
so listen there is a a tremendous
correlation between the things that
happen uh chemically inside your body
your mental health your spiritual
well-being the quality of your
relationships
not to mention the actual mathematics of
going to work that's exactly right you
could find yourself
theoretically getting ahead i wouldn't
say by much but getting ahead
financially but uh falling behind
emotionally falling behind spiritually
falling behind professionally look
depression is a real thing when you're
not doing something that you feel like
i'm accomplishing something that really
starts to set in and you've got to be
very careful and i think this is where
we get into where we've got government
policy that is disincentivizing people
to get out and to contribute well to
become
what they were designed to yes that's
not designed to be a couch potato no you
were created to contribute to work
there's no question about that and and i
think you're absolutely right it's just
how many of us i mean even if you're
doing something like even just cutting
the grass i'm not saying i'm not saying
for money necessarily i'm saying when
you do something that and you can look
at the
the fruit of your labor yes and you feel
a sense of accomplishment there's all
kinds of things that happen not only in
society but inside of you that are
positive that do not happen when you're
sitting on your butt one of my favorite
things to do around the house is
pressure washing i get tremendous joy
out of seeing the before and after and
it feels really good to sit back even
though you know it may be hot when
you're doing it you say look this is
better now because i actually applied
you know
some basic
diligence here to hold a wand and
shoot water pressure at something you're
right there is a sense of accomplishment
accomplishment and there's things that
that changes the way you walk yeah it
changes your posture it changes the way
you relate to other people it changes
your ability and your quality of your
generosity yeah it changed i mean
there's a there's a whole soup of things
here it's not as simple as
oh i'm beating the system
i don't have to work and the
government's going to take care of me i
and listen if you if you're down on your
luck i get it i'm not mad at you i'm not
here to pick on you that's not the thing
the the the point is though that that
choosing and we've got these numbers
that are telling us that there's a large
number of americans they may not be
listeners to this show sure i'm probably
not attracted to this show probably but
but there's a large number of people
based on those numbers
that could be working and just are
choosing not to that's exactly right and
when you're working you're making
progress whether it's paying off debt or
are funding your weight or getting
qualified to do the work you want to do
you're going to have to work at some
point you're going to have to and
sitting at home right now and here's the
other thing this is not going to stay
this way
this is not going to stay this way
forever this is a great time to move to
actually get hired and i think of a
young person you think of somebody right
now going all right i went to college
or i never got the chance to go to
college i couldn't afford it instead of
community college why don't you go work
for a big time company he's going to pay
your way to get a degree they're going
to fund your future i don't know why you
wouldn't do that who cares if you don't
love stocking shelves i'm stocking
shelves for my future yep
yep it's perspective
it's just a great place to go when
you're broke to work
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk to you about
your life your money your career the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five
two two five
open phones and up next is nick in
hartford connecticut hi nick welcome to
the ramsey show
all right thank you for taking nicole
sure what's up
so i'm starting a new job next week for
making forty thousand but i have a
hundred thousand in debt almost all the
student loans about five thousand was on
credit cards
i just started watching your videos on
youtube and realizing wow
you know
really dumb mistakes
um and so i know i need to go through
the baby steps and take all that what i
was going to do was restructure my debt
to more favorable favorable terms but i
wanted to see what your opinion was on
that to make sure i'm not making another
you know big mistake
restructure your student loans
yeah so my student loans about 67 000 of
them are private with a high interest
rate
um and i've gotten a quote on how i can
get you know refinance that into one at
a much lower rate
do it
yeah lower rates not bad as unless
there's a prepayment penalty make sure
there's no prepayment penalty and then
get about the business of cleaning these
things up uh once you get settled into
this new job i want you to pick up a
second job
and uh make another 40k and throw it all
at this dad i want you to be debt-free
in two years
okay i mean really get after it man i
mean nick i want you to go cray-cray man
i want you to go nuts where your friends
think you need counseling because all
you do is work and pay debt
okay
i mean it cause wouldn't it be cool to
be done with this in two years
definitely yeah that's 40 45 000 a year
gets you there
and so that means you got to make 40 you
got to live on less than the 40 that
you're making now you need to go make
another 40 on top of this as your extra
part-time job and you'll be done in two
years
but all you're gonna do all you're gonna
do for two years is work
but you're gonna clean up this whole
mess in two years and you won't even be
what 25 years old will you
i'm 26 now okay well then you'd be 28
years old and you're completely free
or you can be 38 years old and still
screwing around with this stuff like
most people
okay that's really your two options you
got to get with it or not
and what ken and i were just talking
about there's lots of opportunities out
there i mean again you can pick up 40
hours
of extra job at walmart at 15 an hour
that's 30 000 a year which means i know
you can do better than that even
so that's just exactly what i was
talking about yeah and 80 hours a week i
don't want to be working holiday you're
not going to be workaholic you're
working for two years with a goal a
workaholic is someone who is mentally
imbalanced and gets all of their uh
you know gets all this
they're addicted to work mentally that's
not what we're suggesting working hard
is not workaholism working a lot is not
workaholism it's called getting out of a
gum mess
and you just get back you get with it i
mean he can do a lot of stuff oh tons of
stuff i mean again the the look the
minimum wage is out of place right now
that if if you don't
uh find something it's because you're
not looking that's the reality if you
want to find something to get out of
debt it's there
big time you show up with a smile
and and some character you're going to
get 15 an hour or more and you can get
out of debt quick i'm telling you if the
demand is so hot right now it's
unbelievable yeah
if you don't then you're gonna just wake
up 10 years from now and here's the
thing
two years from today the market won't be
like this it will not
the job market comes and goes like all
parts of the economy
it has swings to it mary's with us mary
is in austin texas hi mary how are you
hi i'm fine thanks for taking my call
sure what's up um my husband is retiring
from the military and he's going to
start another job with a government
agency we have a tsp and i was wondering
if you have any advice
on whether we should roll out our tsp
into a separate retirement account and
start a new one at the new job or do we
can continue to contribute to our
current tsp
uh i would roll it
to an individual ira
there's no taxes in doing that and
because you can find mutual funds in the
open market that outperform the tsp
options
okay the c plan is not bad
we tell folks to put 80 percent in the c
10 in the s and 10 percent and the i
is how we tell you to allocate your tsp
but you can get mutual funds that will
outperform that mix if you go to a good
investment advisor like one of our
smartvestor pros so just go to
ramseysolutions.com click smart vester
and find one of the pros in your area
sit down talk to them understand what
you're doing and what i would do is roll
it over to an individual ira a
traditional ira and put it in four types
of mutual funds growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international and
then when he starts the new position he
can start the tsp fresh and just again
80
c
10
s and 10
i is how i would allocate that and
that's going to give you the best rate
of return okay okay thank you so much
thanks for calling in open phones here
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five sawyer is with us in hickory
north carolina hey sawyer what's up
hey dave how you doing i appreciate you
taking my call sure how can i help
uh well i've got a question for you uh
i've recently it's me trying to make a
decision on something uh so i have a
possible expense uh that i would be
committed to for a year
it would be roughly 400 a month so my
current
home expenses are a little less than
half of my current take-home pay
that's including you know rent the only
thing i owe for is a is a truck
and uh the truck payments are a little
over 400 a month
but uh i did that specifically because
i'm trying to get this thing paid off
because i've been i've listened to you
for a long time i don't like being in
debt if i am i don't want to be long how
much do you owe on the truck
uh the truck is about 14 000 left and
your household income is what
uh roughly a month it is uh right at
2700 a month
pretty expensive truck
yeah it uh i was not at the well the
reason i ended up looking for a truck
was thanks to a girl that rear-ended my
old one
but uh i was originally looking for an
older truck and uh
really after listening to you for so
long but uh it ended up being that i got
this truck and uh so i've got a little
over three years left to go
uh on it because i got it for four years
and uh
specifically wanted to if i was going to
get something like that i knew i'd have
higher payments but i wanted to get it
paid off as quickly as i could but the
expense that i've got coming up though
that i'm trying to decide on is uh i
told the lady on here that you might
find slightly amusing is uh
there is a hair
type
product online like that's supposed to
try to help you regrow hair
and it would be almost another four
hundred dollars a month so
i tried to do my numbers on my current
expenses and so
my expenses per month are roughly a
little over
1200 a month
that's including that truck and that's
also including me putting back for a
retirement fund that i have so that's
all of my expenses except for say
holy how old are you sawyer
27 okay
all right
cool um well you make
thirty eight thousand dollars a year
forty thousand dollars a year you have a
fourteen thousand dollar truck and
you're putting money into investments
and you just went and bought the truck
on payments
um and 100 of the things you've
described are things that we tell you
not to do right
is that right
i mean do you how long have you listened
to the show
well for for a long time but it has
actually been several years since i've
got to listen again
let's to be fair to you then let's recap
all right what we would tell you to do
is to become debt free first after you
have one thousand dollars saved you have
any money in savings
uh yes you're about fifty five hundred
dollars good okay
uh you now have one thousand dollars and
you put forty five hundred on your
fourteen thousand dollar truck and that
leaves you ten or nine thousand five
hundred dollars left on the truck uh you
also have an extra job now and you're
gonna pay that truck off in a very very
short period of time when you do that
you're gonna finish your emergency oh by
the way you stopped all your long-term
investing temporarily today too
because you're going to work the baby
steps
and then once you're debt free and you
have your emergency fund in place
then if you want to do the hair regrowth
program and you want to pay for that
that's when you would do it at that
point
i'm not sure i would do it obviously i
haven't done it
so i was going to ask him
it was it was a no-go i was going to ask
for you if i did not try it but if i had
tried it obviously it didn't work
you can listen to all our shows with the
ramsay network app on your smartphone
browse by topic or even sync clips to
your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice ken coleman ramsey personality is
my co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five
five
two two
five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money
so
college
has gotten
crazy
it's crazy expensive we've all known
that we've got this epic
student loan
debacle
pandemic financial pandemic
that is eaten eating away at the very
fabric
of our
culture and as of 2019 if your kid went
to a four-year school
tuition ran somewhere between 20 and 40
000 bucks
somewhere around there
um
and
depending on the you know that that's
the average that would include
you can go for about 10 12 000 a year to
an in-state school tuition
certainly private is going to be a lot
more than that and all kinds of ranges
on the private side
but if you're going to save for college
we have always taught to use the 529 one
particular type and the particular type
of 529 there's several types
the the only one you want is the type
that allows you to select the mutual
funds and allows you to move the mutual
funds if you don't like them
you don't want to get into a fixed plan
uh you don't want to get into a plan
that automatically does your investment
mix
danger
you don't want to get into a plan that's
prepaid tuition
you want to get into a plan where you
pick the mutual funds and you have the
right and the ability to move them
you always have that right and ability
with the esa the educational savings
account both the 529 and the esa will
grow completely tax-free
and that tax-free growth
makes a big difference if you when you
start with
a baby and you're saving for 18 years
because you could have 100 150 000 in
there and
really over half of it be growth and no
taxes
that matters oh big time
so we want to get the tax-free bonus the
tax-free growth
and so we always have taught you to go
in baby step five
the first two thousand dollars a year
you can do as an esa it's real easy to
set up and it grows tax-free it's
basically a roth ira for college
the 529 if you want to do more than 2
000 a year is available if you select
that particular
type
of 529
and uh you got to be careful you got to
watch what you're doing and you need
some help in this to walk you through it
and the trick is to get with one of our
smart vester pros and let them lead you
through the process i mean we've got the
book by anthony o'neill debt-free degree
there's a lot of ways that in today's
job market uh we were talking in another
hour walmart target mcdonald's some of
these 15 an hour jobs now
and in this current environment they're
paying
um
you know they're paying for tuition yes
but if you're not in that kind of a
thing and you don't want to depend on
that kind of thing always being there so
you want to save for your kids college
in baby step five so that it so you
don't become your kid doesn't become a
statistic of student loan debt
so text invest to 33
789
and we'll hook you up with a ramsey
vetted ramsey trusted
smart vester pro
now what the smart vester pros are is
these are investment brokers that we
have vetted they have a the heart of a
teacher they're going to teach you the
529 teach you the esa
teach you the mutual funds to put in it
and show you how you can get the
tax-free growth going in your favor
and um
two really good solid savings options
there and how the mutual funds work so
that you know what you're getting into
in the whole process here so if you're
ready to get your baby step 5 going
you're ready to start saving for your
kids college
new baby on the scene that kind of thing
you're ready to go text invest
to 33
7
89 and between doing that and using some
common sense you should not have student
loan debt under any circumstances
correct and how about this let's just
throw something else in there parents
we've got to ask the question uh if our
kiddo has an idea what they want to do
now they've got to get clear on this
is it the only way is it the best way
it's a two-part question is traditional
college education the only way
is it the best way uh it's still a great
experience you know the liberal arts are
wonderful experience for people to learn
but we've got to make sure that that
we're choosing or helping our kids
choose the right path to go do what they
want to do and you know between
community college maybe a two-year
associates maybe all they need and then
some specific certification and training
to go a path too so we've got to look at
the big picture and not just assume that
higher ed is the only way my kiddo
or that we if we're transitioning from
one crew to next is the only way we get
there sometimes it is there's absolutely
no way around it here's what's
interesting when you spend
money
that you have saved
diligently over a number of years
you are much more careful that's exactly
right with the purchase sure than you
are if you just go
yeah get a sign on the dotted line and
borrow the money and walk out of here
and impulse my butt into something and
that's what people that's how people
pick the wrong college yep the wrong
university
that's too expensive that they can't
afford
that's how they pick bad degrees because
they just go well i just signed up i
just went there was very little thought
that went into it but when you have
saved for 18 freaking years in your esa
for your kid and your kid comes in and
wants to do something stupid you say no
yeah you slam the brakes no you're not
doing something stupid yeah you're not
going to study some nuanced ridiculous
degree in left-handed puppetry and spend
the money that i've saved for 18
freaking years to do that here's another
one i cited the wall street journal
article uh on columbia uh various you
know you know big time name brand in new
york and they followed a story of a guy
dave who got his film degree a graduate
level degree in film from columbia
and
he's 333 thousand dollars in debt he's
working in la making 60 000 a year well
i got news for you you don't need a
columbia
grad degree in film studies to get a 60
000 job in los angeles you just don't
you could use my proximity principle
book which will sell you for a great
discount at ramsey solutions.com less
than 333 000 we will less than 333
thousand dollars and this this
considerably considerably but this guy's
talking about he says i'm in debt for
life
yeah and you could hear it even though
it was a written article you could hear
the pain coming off this poor young guy
and here's what's happening i bring this
point up to say that the name brand
school there's no statistical data that
i'm aware of there's no piece of
research that i'm aware of in 30 years
that says that the the the sexier the
name of the school the bigger the
paycheck nobody cares in the horrible in
the borrowed future podcast uh seth
godin calls them famous schools fema
he's right famous schools they're famous
schools that's all they are you went to
a famous school yeah you know that gets
you bragging rights at the cocktail
party nothing else nothing does it get
you more respect or more pay
i you know i yeah for fun
i got a sweatshirt when we were in
boston
it says harvard on it yeah
i remember do you cut the grass in it
you don't even cut the grass what am i
talking about
i don't even have a sweatshirt oh you
just bought it i bought it but it didn't
last i mean did you burst wasn't funny
did you burn it in efficiency me wearing
a harvard shirt was just not
it was not believable oh no no chance no
one no one would everybody would look
and go no that didn't happen
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today author of the number one
bestselling book the proximity principle
and a brand new book that is on pre-sale
right now
called from paycheck to purpose the
clear path to doing work you love boise
idaho andrews on the line hey andrew how
can we help
i'm doing well thanks for taking my call
today sure what's up
um so my question is is it worth leaving
a job that i don't hate
that also is not fulfilling
if i have to take a pay cut to do so
well i just have a question on that is
that the only option you have to leave
this unfulfilling job is a job that pays
less
well it would be
it would take me two or three years to
get back up to where i am now in a new
field why
um because i do not have the
um the technical skills in that field so
i'd be switching from uh sales to
accounting do you want to do accounting
long term or take accounting and take it
higher
um i want to do accounting
long term as a cta
working with small businesses okay great
and so what's the qualification process
look like how much financial is that
going to cost you
um so depending on the year but um
30 to 60 percent pay cut
so i guess this year it
so i make my base salary is about
65 000 a year yeah and then i bonus
um
this year i'll probably bonus a little
over a hundred thousand so you make a
hundred sixty five thousand dollars a
year
uh no sorry um
with the bonus
total with the bonus statement okay so
you make a hundred thousand dollars a
year
yes
okay and you're how old
uh 30. okay
okay so the question i have though is
there's some training not just
experience how much is the training
going to cost you the certification to
become a cpa what's that actual cost
um so i have some school towards it
already right so i'd have about two and
a half years of school left
the programs i've been looking at it
would cost me probably about 15 thousand
to twenty thousand to finish up okay so
the reason that i don't think you need
to take a pay cut is we we can stay in
an unfulfilling job
if it allows us to make the kind of
money we need to cash flow and not go
into debt or pay off any other debt that
you have to be able to move into the
accounting field but if you take a
significant pay cut it takes everything
much longer do you understand what i'm
saying
i do so with the pay cut i would be
um
i would be able to
still do it within the three years
um
i want to do it in one year and not take
a pay cut
fair enough that's i think you've
created a false narrative
okay you don't have to take a pay cut
correct um
the struggle i have now is i work
about 50 to 60 hours a week and so
finding time
for school
i have young kids at home
finding the time for school
is difficult
if that makes sense
it makes sense but it's a separate
conversation you know that first it's
like hey so i take a pay cut
i don't think you need to take a pay cut
you shouldn't take a pay cut uh but but
but you still have got to figure out
what what do i have to do to get where i
want to go and i get that you got small
kids but they're small kids they're
young kids they don't know how much time
you're spending with them is this comes
down to how much you really want to get
where you want to go and what sacrifices
you're going to have to make
you know in this particular situation
you're going to have to sacrifice
financially uh in that you're saving up
money to pay for the qualifications you
need you're gonna have to sacrifice some
time with the kids
uh that's just your reality but that's a
short season this is not for five years
yeah for 12 months yeah
right
the kids will be
the opportunity um with this particular
accounting firm is now i guess that's
kind of the
so what that's not the only accounting
firm that will hire you and give you the
opportunity to climb a lab it's not an
opportunity
it's a curse it takes you backwards
fair enough are they gonna you know
the opportunity would be great if they
offered you 80 grand and paid for your
tuition and you worked 40 hours a week
so that you could go ahead and instead
of 60 hours a week at your sales job
take a small pay cut but when you're
talking about taking a 40 or 50 or 65
pay cut that's just as silly man this
doesn't work
that's so far backward that that you're
you're you're short-circuiting the whole
process by doing that but if they you
know if these guys really want you
then hey they're going to pay you
you know they're asking listen listen
let me just tell i'm an employer okay we
are 300 people this year the number of
people that i hire
at 65 000 a year
that took a pay cut from 165 000 this
year will be precisely zero
i wouldn't hire you
fair enough because it's silly
even if you're going working for ramsey
i've always wanted to work for dave
ramsey he's the best guy on the planet i
think he's the most wonderful bull crap
you're taking us
165 to 65 cut
or from a hundred thousand down to sixty
five thousand dollar cut
and you know
i'm a great guy i'm not that great don't
do it yeah
uh andrew final word on this you've got
to change your mindset about this
current day job that's unfulfilling it
doesn't matter you do what you have to
do so you can do what you want to do and
you got to change your mindset change
your entire attitude i'm grateful for
this job because it is setting me up for
a future that has to change and then lay
in place a game plan that you
strategically get after
making this accounting process happen
for you go get your cpa
go get it yeah go get it pay the price
pay the price to win
and you know uh but i think you go back
to this accounting firm and you say look
guys i'm not moving from a hundred
thousand
to fifty thousand
it doesn't make sense yeah
what kind of an accountant would i be if
i thought that was a good idea
yeah it's absolutely right
you should be able to do math to do
accounting and so yeah i mean so i can't
do that and so if you guys can give me a
much less hit down to about 80 and
you'll pick up my tuition and help me
get the cpa then this is then it's worth
taking a little step back
to move forward but yeah this is just
too deep a cut i wouldn't do it no you
do what you want to do you called us and
asked we're both telling you no
dave here's something here there's some
psychology around opportunities and this
is a great situation here to to unpack
this just because it is an opportunity
doesn't mean it is a good opportunity we
just walk through this this is a bad
opportunity it is yes it's an
opportunity to do accounting work and to
get there but it revolves around too
many other harmful decisions slow
decisions poor decisions however you
want to classify it and so
there's this psychology of us humans we
want something really bad we're not in
fulfilling work and we see an
opportunity we make it shinier than it
is you've got to look at the entire
picture around it you know because it's
not the only accounting firm it's not
the only entrance
it's not the only ladder whatever
metaphor you want to use and if it's a
bad move it's a bad move even though
it's an opportunity it's not the only
one
you know this
involves
purchasing things
it involves
any kind of situation where you're
having to make a decision
one rule and i teach this in entre
leadership when i'm teaching
leadership lessons to business people
one rule of decision making if you want
to make a high quality decision
the
there's almost no times that you make a
high quality decision when there's only
two options
you need more options yes lots and lots
and lots of options and as you look at
the different options you go well that's
that's a really bad option and that one
has got some good points to it but it's
still a bad option and that option that
option and you lay them all out there
and if you got 10 different ways you can
do something 10 different
job offers on the table 10 different
places you can purchase a car
10 different cars you can purchase and
you're starting to compare across them
instead of going oh they only have the
black one over there and the black one
and if i don't get the black one and
it's that one thing and it's a very
special oh it's a freaking car
and we get all fatalistic about it and
that's right right about that time is
when you get stupid
so you need more options
so that you find a good one
and that's the process
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show in
the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage tim is with us hey tim
how are you i'm i'm well gentlemen
thanks for having me honored to have you
sir where do you live uh on rockford
minnesota okay
minneapolis area yeah a small town a
little west yeah cool welcome welcome to
nashville how much have you paid off 77
479. excellent and how long did this
take you 13 crazy months
and your range of income during that 13
crazy months
i went from 49 000 up to 75 000. wow
what do you do for a living i'm an
elementary school physical education
teacher and then for the 13 months i was
delivering pizzas for dominoes and i
worked a golf course for a while wow
anything it took huh yeah pretty much
scratch and claw and get it done yes
love it what kind of debt was the 77 000
i had a little over 8 000 in a car loan
and then the remainder was student loans
student loan student loan student loans
here we go i love it very cool so what
happened to you 13 months ago that made
you go crazy like this
so uh
before i can kind of share the the debt
payoff story i want to tell a story that
kind of informs how i had the energy and
the motivation to do it um coming out of
high school i was close to 400 pounds
very unhealthy just not really taking
care of myself and
back then is when i kind of first
discovered what gazelle intensity was
before i even had any idea of your
teachings
um ended up getting into the gym and you
know just working hard seven days a week
and
and i was able to get myself down to to
a healthy range and and uh take care of
things there and
um that's amazing oh yeah thank you so
much so you lost over 200 pounds yeah
yeah
unfortunately after that some life
happened and i did go back up a little
bit i was i was up to 336 pounds again
but then
it was three years ago or so i got back
on it and
you know got back on the right path and
now i'm back down to where i was pre
putting it back so
fast forward to the debt uh i had a
conversation with my cousin's husband
alan he had uh
read your book and did debt payoff of
his own and uh he asked me if i had any
sort of plan in place for my student
loans or if they were just going to hang
out forever which at the time my plan
really wasn't a plan i was
signed up for the public service loan
forgiveness and i just assumed you know
i'd make minimum payments and eventually
it would be forgiven
um alan pointed out that
something like one percent of people who
had applied that were were receiving
forgiveness and it wasn't much of a plan
at all
and that's where we put together a
budget and
came up with a plan at the time we said
was going to be 24 months to get rid of
it um i already had
close to 10 000 in the bank so that was
just pay off the car got your emergency
fund figured out and we were off to the
races from there yeah
okay cool so he he lined you up on how
to do this then yes sir all right very
cool and then how did you connect up
with us just through him yeah so he gave
me a copy of your book i read the total
money makeover and went through
financial peace university and it was
instantly hooked just as fast as i took
to the gym years ago i just dove in and
got to work okay so yeah you had already
figured out through your weight loss and
everything and your your career choice
and everything else that you can control
the guy in your mirror yeah and that
wasn't a revelation to you you just had
to apply it to the money piece yeah yeah
i just hadn't done it in the financial
side of things before so it was a
somewhat easy transition in that sense
yeah i got to ask you because you you
shared uh uh i was really compelling how
you went back a little bit on the weight
yeah did you have that happen on this
debt-free journey or were you just laser
focused and you never stopped were you
kind of like a wood chipper just
throwing logs in there yeah it was it
was wood chipper this time right for the
for the debt uh there was really nothing
stopping it the only there was only you
know a couple of times along the way
where i just felt tired but never never
really wavered or went back how many
hours you just described for us pizza
working at a golf course how many hours
did you log what was the longest week at
the peak of it i think i put in 85 86
hours
and i was doing consistently 80.
um very fortunate to have understanding
and patient friends and family and my
wonderful fiance who i met actually
during that time um how it doesn't seem
like you had any time to meet a woman i
know
online dating it worked out oh okay all
right
good for you man that's incredible and
waved and went on to your next job
we had to get creative in finding ways
to find time for each other but uh we
made it now we're here and now you're
free how does it feel to be free oh it's
incredible i i can't it's hard to
describe honestly will you will you go
back will you add this back
into that no sir never yeah all right
good
good i'm glad to hear that you're a hero
man proud of you very well done thank
you very very very proud of you
excellent excellent job so what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is you know for me it was honestly
just letting go of the idea that there
was a
magic pill silver bullet or white knight
coming to save me
there isn't there's nothing but you and
good old-fashioned hard work and you
just got to put in the time also
finding what's important and making sure
that they remain a priority you know
during that time i was working 80 hours
a week but i did see my girlfriend at
the time fiance now and made time to see
family and things like that so
very cool it's all about the balance
right very cool well done man well done
very well done excellent excellent job
what was the hardest part the hours yeah
it was tough well and um so as as the
relationship with with bree grew um i
was just i started to get her to get to
know her kids more and things like that
and then they
are starting to want more time with me
and that's when i knew it was time to
quit the dominoes um you know when got
little girls at home wondering when tim
was gonna be around i was like okay
we're done with that but um so the last
couple of months i it was just my
teaching salary that that we did it with
okay so you kind of that's cool very
cool when you can see the end it's easy
to make some adjustments yeah and you
gotta bust into it until you can see the
end yeah
very well very well done good job man
hey thank you well we got a copy of the
legacy journey for you and uh that's the
next chapter in your story for sure to
build and create a whole new legacy with
this new marriage coming up and
everything do you have a date set
not yet this is actually very very
recent uh i proposed on my trip here so
this just happened we actually went to
ruby falls and yeah chattanooga oh so
beautiful
proposed down in the cave i didn't have
a ring at the time because it wasn't
planned but i'm like i'm never going to
be able to beat this moment down in the
cave by 100 foot waterfall so i just
decided to do that and then we went ring
shopping the next day oh that's great
congratulations oh thank you very much
congrats that's excellent best part of
the ring shopping thing was uh i told
the gentleman that i was going to be on
your show and he started to talk about
and he caught himself as he was
explaining like financing options i'm
like
[Laughter]
yeah i don't think that's going to work
out
[Laughter]
that's fun
very cool dude well that is fun and we
got a copy of total money makeover for
you to give away to somebody as well so
legacy journey total money makeover
thank you man we appreciate you very
well done very proud of you and congrats
and thanks for uh
thanks for making us part of your whole
story here that's a beautiful story i
appreciate you guys thank you very cool
all right tim from the minneapolis area
77 000
paid off in 13 months how
80 hour weeks
49 000 to 75 000 during that time and
now he's free and can work however he
wants to work nowadays count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream all right
here we go three two one i'm debt-free
[Applause]
that is how it's done right there
you know it's it's almost as if today
our theme has been hard work yes through
all three hours today and we've seen
examples of people who have done it and
examples of people who
couldn't figure it out
don't want to try it don't even want to
work hard
and this guy man he's a machine
and
turn around looks these two two little
girls they're starting to count on him
this relationship is growing and says uh
i'm going to dial it back now that's
right because i can see the finish line
and get on across the finish line that's
huge it's really huge what you see there
is the the commitment to a future a
desired future and then all of a sudden
uh the relationship piece comes in he
goes okay i'm gonna dial it back and i'm
still gonna finish i might finish a
little bit slower time if you will but
it mattered so much because of this
beautiful relationship and those little
girls i mean this is what it's all about
it's so much bigger than us you know
money
uh it holds us back
from really the desired future that we
all along for what an incredible story
what a hero 85 hours at his top week
that is that's busting gazelle if there
is a gazelle that's it that's getting it
that's getting it i love it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 9 10
the fear of the lord is the foundation
of wisdom and knowledge
of the holy one results in good judgment
one half of knowing what you want is
knowing what you must give up before you
get it mitch album said
our question today comes from blinds.com
great american company find out for
yourself why blinds.com is the number
one online window
retailer window custom window coverings
this is an incredible company you get
free samples free shipping and with the
new promos they run every month you'll
save even more use the promo code ramsay
to get the best possible deal today's
question comes from rihanna in toronto
she says i'm 28 years old i've been in
my retail job for 10 years i've gone
from a temporary associate to supervisor
but now that i've made it there
i'm miserable to pay down debt i
recently started a second job as a hotel
night shift auditor and i love
everything about it i think it's my
calling my day job pays more than my
night job would pay in a full-time
position should i stay at my day job
until i'm debt free even though i hate
it
well dave a lot of layers to this onion
uh but yeah you should stay at your day
job until you can replace that day job
with something that you enjoy a whole
lot more but to move into this new found
i think it's my calling job uh that pays
a whole lot less is not a good move
while you're paying off debt this gets
to what we were talking about earlier
that you know when we find something
that we enjoy we want to do it the
reality is there's always a financial
cost whether it's to get qualified or
uh in taking a pay cut
it's just not a good move in her
situation you've got to get debt free
when you get debt free keep walking the
baby steps out and then we can begin the
process of moving into
a similar work to that night auditor
that pays a lot better they got to look
into what is the work the part of the
night auditor job that i love so much
let's find similar work like that that
has a ladder of opportunity that's what
i would tell her yeah and then let's get
up that ladder yeah because i think
auditor would pay more than retail
supervisor yeah they should yeah they
should i mean i don't know what type of
auditing you're looking at but there's a
lot of different categories that that
could fall in that's right and that
would probably scratch the itch that
you've got the thing that you like about
the job yeah john is with us in reno
nevada hi john welcome to the ramsey
show
hey ken and dave thanks so much i'm
pretty nervous so um
i'm gonna try to summarize my question
real quick so i work for a company i'm a
manager i report to all of the corporate
leadership equally and uh
right now i'm kind of struggling in my
job because
there's a lot of factors but basically
i'm finding that my values are at odds
with theirs and how i want to do my work
the way that they have me do my work i'm
not proud of it and it's really really
highly stressing me out my wife and i
are on baby step number two and we um
i we make 150 about 150 000 a year total
together what do you mean so my question
i make a hundred thousand myself okay
and what is it that they're asking you
to do that you don't want to do
so it's just there's nothing immoral or
unethical it's it's kind of the way that
they want me to do my work for example
look at me a project i'll be almost 90
done with it then they trash it and it
happens over and over again they're very
disorganized the corporate team is is
this unified they have clicks that
disagree with each other and i'm caught
in the middle and i i'll follow orders
from this person then the other person
will tell me stop so i have to stop i've
asked them to get unified but they it's
just their modus operandi it's the way
they've always run this company and i
don't see it changing
what do you do
um i'm a
i'm a i'm a medical clinic manager
so give me an example of they've asked
you to do a project you do it and or
you're 90 done and then they trash it i
want to know the why they would trash it
in that example
yeah a good example would be uh they
wanted to start a pharmacy department so
i was laying the groundwork for that
compliance-wise hiring-wise uh we were
in our final interview with the
pharmacist you're gonna hire and the
next day they canceled the project the
reason was finances and that's
understandable to me it's just a
complete lack of planning and total
disorganization they don't really have a
they don't really budget carefully and
they don't really follow their plans
okay so when they communicated that the
finances weren't there you understood
that but but the issue is they just kind
of set you off on this path and they
didn't do the planning that irritates
you and you're getting to a point where
you're getting really frustrated so
you're working for you're working for a
group of medical people and your job's
to run the business
yeah my job is to run the clinic here
and it's uh separate from where the
corporate office is yeah huh so what was
your question you're about ready to get
to the question and we asked you some
questions what was your big question
yeah my big question is um how quickly
should i leave because i'm pretty sure
i'm gonna need to leave i just don't
know how hard to push it i would like to
leave right away my heart's kind of left
yeah but uh you know we're in we're in
step number two and
uh we're making really good money and if
i were to leave we i want to get out of
um i want to get out of the state we're
in and uh
if i were to leave it would be a move
and a pay cut at least at this point
because i'm very inexperienced and i
don't have a degree so entry level i
basically be an
entry level manager at whatever position
i take up
well this is a math thing so we don't
leave until we've got a something good
to leave too i understand that you're in
a really tough situation where your
hearts
left you and in a normal situation if
you had no debt and you could just move
quickly
then i'd say leave quickly but i think
that you've got to keep this path going
to where you're paying off the debt you
guys are making really good money i
would challenge your assumption
that you moving into
another opportunity where you're running
a clinic that you'd have to start all
over i mean you've got some good
experience been running this clinic yeah
a year and a half then why couldn't you
go run another clinic who says you can't
go who says you have to take a pay cut
that's absolute bs
yeah i i guess the root also the root of
my question is just how
you know the company really loves me
they're always telling me they love me
they're putting a lot of trust in me
they've depended on me a lot i don't
think that matters i think you left
yeah
you're you're sick and tired of their
disorganization and the chaos yeah and
the disrespect of your work yeah it's
only going to get worse for you unless
they somehow they're not going to not
they're not going to fix this you're
gone so where are you getting this idea
that you have to take a pay cut
just uh jobs we're looking at in other
areas we'd want to move they usually
start around 60 000 up to 80 or 90 000
and um so i think you need to get an 80
or a 90 000 job lined up and so you quit
your hundred thousand dollar job and
then 90 000 has an upside of 120.
yep and you don't you don't think it's
like
i guess i'm really emotionally like
you're shot right up in it because the
company's been so good to me other than
okay
they have not been good to you yeah
there's some guilt you're dealing with
because you think that they've done all
this for you and you leaving them is
going to make you a bad guy that's
simply not the case
you don't owe them a life of mediocrity
their disaster you're going to end up
resenting these people that you're
worried about disappointing resentment
well yeah yeah so i mean yeah
there's no reason for guilt none
none this is not your mama it's your
boss
yeah i mean you know go you just it's a
job go you know go get a position with
somebody that's organized and that has a
game plan and has a mission and you can
lead the charge in the mission and go
land a job and then turn in your
two-week notice and move out of nevada
to the place that you're gonna go work
yeah i have one other thing on this my
family is telling me i need to stay
because
i'm the kind of person that will help
them get organized your family is not in
charge of your life you are in charge of
your life yeah i know i just and you
spent the last five minutes telling us
how crummy a place this is and how
stressed out you are and then you spent
the next three minutes trying to talk us
into how wonderful it is i mean how
you're a superman and you're there to
save them you're the savior this is a
bunch of crap man you need to quit yeah
i get after breaking the news dave his
family
is not telling him to stay because they
think he can turn it around his family's
told him to stay because they don't want
him to leave
breaking news right there
i know
i know
oh they're in nevada yeah yeah his
family is saying i think you should stay
because you're the one guy who can turn
these wildcats into properly trained
felines no they don't want you to leave
we're gonna get these butterflies to fly
in formation right family doesn't want
him to leave yeah that's so sorry or
they're just afraid also and that's okay
yeah so john you need to go get another
job make a 90 with an upside of 120 in a
state that you want to live in and you
need to take accept the position and
then turn in your two week notice sir
that's the answer to you you're not
you're not gonna be happy five years
from now if you stay in this job
it's not going there
that puts us hour of the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you